[MUSIC PLAYING]
STEPHANIE WONG: One of the
linchpins of on-prem systems
is the aggressive
use of IP addresses
to balance, scatter,
and manage traffic
coming into your environment.
This is built into the
configuration of your routers,
firewalls, and most of the
hardware and software you've
got lying around.
As you migrate portions of
your environment to the cloud,
however, you have to be aware
that this IP address logic will
change in various ways.
As such, it's crucial to plan
ahead for your IP address
changes that could
affect your workloads
and how they interact with
internal and public network
traffic.
In this episode, I'll be
covering private and public IPs
on Google Cloud, and how
you can achieve remappable
IP addresses for
your cloud resources.
Stay tuned.
The main challenge is
that you can't simply
move your existing IP
addresses to the cloud
along with your services.
Cloud providers and data
centers have a limited pool
of IP addresses that
they own, and they often
reuse previously-assigned IPs
in order to maximize them.
The result is that your
services will receive
a dynamically-assigned internal
and public IP address, which
by default are
ephemeral, meaning
if you restart those instances,
you'll lose those IPs.
For companies in
this situation, there
are basically two solutions
which you could run through.
Define firewall rules by using
tags instead of IP addresses.
Forward traffic
through a managed load
balancer with a static IP.
Of course, both will
work, but they both
come with a large downside.
As your cloud IPs
continue to change,
they'll break any dependencies
your services might
have on those IPs
which are hardcoded
or require a network
admin to manually change,
which can quickly turn into
a nightmare of maintenance.
For example, let's say you spin
up your first back-end machines
in the cloud and decide to tear
them down for a period of time
to save on costs.
Suddenly, when you're ready to
get them up and running again,
you'll notice that you lost
those dynamically-assigned IPs,
only to find new ones.
Now you have to reconfigure
your on-prem app
and any firewall rules to
point to the new public IP
of your cloud back-end.
This can grow pretty
tiresome and unwieldy
over large environments.
Thankfully, Google
Cloud allows you
to get around this
situation by reserving
static IPs for your services.
So if your VM is
shut down, you can
retain the same
internal and public IPs
when you spin it back up.
What this means is that
you can feel relaxed
knowing that if you point
a forwarding rule, firewall
rule, or application
to your cloud instance
IP from within or out
of the VPC network,
you won't need to
reconfigure the IPs each time
you shut down your instances.
This really comes
in handy if you
are dependent on a specific
IP address for your service
and need to prevent your
teammates from being
able to use that address.
And the best part?
You can even promote a
previously ephemeral IP
to be a static one, helping you
cut corners in a few places.
Let's dive into IPs a bit more.
For Compute Engine, you can
assign one internal and one
public IP address for each VM.
It's important to
note that you don't
need public IPs for your
VMs within the same VPC
to communicate,
and this can really
help network performance.
On the other hand, if you
need the VM to communicate
with the internet or any VM
in a different VPC network,
your VM has to have
a public IP address,
unless you've set up
some sort of proxy or VPN
in the other network.
For both cases of internal
and public IP addresses,
you can choose ephemeral
and static IPs.
Let's start with internal IPs.
When you create a VM, unless
you specify an internal IP
within your subnet
range, Google will just
assign your VM an
ephemeral internal IP
from your subnet range.
You can reserve one later
on and assign it to your VM
if you decide you need a
static internal IP later.
For public IPs,
the same applies.
Unless you assign your VM a
reserved static public IP,
Google will assign an ephemeral
public IP randomly from a pool,
or you can choose not to
assign a public IP whatsoever,
which can be good
for keeping instances
from being exposed to
the public internet
and reduce security risk.
Later on, you can
always assign one.
There's also a way to create
a custom public IP on GCP, as
well, but I'll point you to
the documentation linked below.
Let's walk through IP setup.
Let's take a look at a VM I just
created with Apache 2 installed
deployed in useast-1.
First, head to the
Networking tab.
By default, you're given an
ephemeral internal and public
address.
I'm going to remove the
ephemeral public IP,
and you can now see it
has no public IP address.
It's important to note that if
you're an internal VM talking
to other internal
VMs, then you need
to be using the internal address
for the best performance.
Otherwise, your internal
VM has to travel back
to the public internet,
which can slow it down.
Now, as I mentioned,
by default, your VMs
will use ephemeral public
IPs, but sometimes you
need static ones that
won't change over time.
Thankfully, you can create
this right in Google Cloud.
Go to the Network tab, and
then in External IP Addresses,
create a static one.
And note that we can also
just promote an ephemeral one.
You want to create the IP in
the same region as the instance,
unless you're doing
global forwarding,
because static IPs are
regional resources.
You can assign the IP to the
instance right from here.
And now you see we have a
new static public IP address
assigned to the instance.
And as long as you
have the right firewall
setup to allow HTTP
traffic on port 80,
now you can see that we
have access to the web page
through the new
static IP address.
Once you understand how
IP addresses are affected
when different
actions are performed
in your overall
architecture, you
start to realize the importance
of using remappable IP
addresses, especially for
front-end servers in the cloud.
But what if you don't want
a public IP address in order
to maintain higher
security, yet you still
want to be able to do
things like fetch updates
from the public internet?
Stay tuned for the next
episode to find out how.
And remember,
optimizing your network
means freeing up your bandwidth.
[MUSIC PLAYING]